what's up guys it's mary and it's a new
week which means it's time for new
releases and this week we're getting HTC
vive which is rad because it's like
being in another world and this week
time is power check out this live action
trailer for the well anticipated quantum
break they spared no expense getting
little finger as the villain oh you love
to hate that guy you play Jack Joyce
person with time manipulation powers in
a world where time stutters making
everything freeze except Joyce you can
stop time temporarily allowing you to
escape from attacks or freeze enemies
unleash a time blast which is an
offensive projectile and reverse the
direction of bullets with a pretty sweet
time stop look like that Quicksilver
seen in x-men stop time on the fifth I
thought it was important to let you note
the vibe comes out this week it's on the
fifth here are some games that also
release this week so you can play it if
you have the hardware the gallery call
of the star seed elite dangerous
fantastic contraption tilt brush job
simulator and final approach there's
more but those are the ones I really
like em with this now why it's one of
our favorite racing games from last year
now on current-gen consoles it's dirt
rally it gives you everything you love
about the pc game but adds more content
and more cars you got seven extra cars
you're gonna want to try out
specifically that pujo t26 Pikes Peak
what step aside baby because my first
love the Impreza livery is coming out
with fluorescent yellow and blue oh my
god you're gonna be able to experience
the vintage full gravel surface at Pikes
Peak whoo vintage it's all here we got
cars they're takin off on the fifth
enter the gungeon is a bullet hell
dungeon crawler following a band of
misfits seeking to shoot lewd and dodge
roll and table flip their way to
personal absolution by reaching the
legendary guns ultimate treasure a gun
that will kill the past
wait when that like erase you or
something anyway you can pick your own
character and go solo or team up and
co-op and battle your way to the bottom
of that gunjan that's out on ps4 and PC
on the fifth oh what a pretty game
lovely planet is but the easy on the
eyes pastel visuals are in fact a lie of
the utmost kind this is in fact a
shooter where everything on this cutesy
planet is coming to get you you gotta
shoot disarm and take down anything in
your path to survive another lovely day
in this delightful delightful deathtrap
this comes out on ps4 and Wii U on the
5th Death Star is an online multiplayer
space shooter combining the fast-paced
feel of arcade classics with modern RPG
elements earn loot and levels as you
fight in procedurally generated levels
to further customize your experience
including a massive warship used to
invade live player matches that's out on
pc and ps4 on the 5th going back to
colorful weird things stick fold is a
groovy 70s themed single and local
multiplayer fantasy dodgeball game it's
got quirky arena's and chaos inducing
random events like land sharks follow
the story of world famous stick bold
athletes be shorn and Jerome play solo
team up with a dodgeball buddy and co-op
battles or charged headfirst into the
manic free-for-all battles with five
others it's got the perfect art style to
match this silly fun couch combat game
dodge duck dip dive and dodge on the
fifth maría norstrom is the newest
expansion to paradox development studios
historical grand strategy game europa
universalis 4 mar i norstrom introduces
new systems connected to naval warfare
and control of trade the power of your
fleets will depend on the number of
sailors your nation can gather and your
ships can now be given missions and
areas to patrol there are also new
options for creating trade leagues and a
host of other improvements this is an
expansion folks you need the game to
enjoy it on the 5th
finally killed to collect be prepared to
earn your keep and die trying as you
travel further down this sleepless
cesspool of murderous vagrants and
cybernetic freaks slicing and dicing
your way to the bottom of your career
kill to collect is a one to four player
co-op roguelike set in an 80s inspired
cyberpunk universe if nothing else
tickles your fancy you can just sit back
and listen to those sick 80s beats and
that's all the games i have for you this
week remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and sometimes
they change I'll catch you guys in the
fourth dimension